glassblowing is particularly effective
in working with students who've been
exposed to traumatic experiences
partially because of the risk that's
involved in working with the material
it's it's potentially dangerous for
working with 2,000 degree molten
material it requires quite a level of
trust to be able to work with the
material
learn how to walk in like and try to run
again I'll let that stuff like I was
like the worst the bullet still in my
leg right now like I've been like kind
of started to change my life around like
ever since like a lot of people I've
been losing a lot of people and stuff
like that
last one I have to do that because
they'll be like you don't like you blow
glass something like that well I can
show them I'm better than like telling
I'm like people look at you different -
like he ain't just trying to be out here
in these streets he trying to really do
some with his life my end-all goal for
the students here is is that they see
other opportunities for themselves in
any field in any medium in any way they
see a sense of future